what's going on reject nation greg and
john here today we are going to watch
today from emergency awesome a turtle's
trailer breakdown marvel celestials and
avengers end game connection explained
yeah if you haven't seen our trailer
reaction go ahead check that out had koi
john drew on from comic book shopping
cheat review with him right afterwards
he had to jet though he had more
important things to do i really love
that trailer let's see what charlie has
to say
[Music]
welcome back everyone big surprise
marvel dropped a new eternals trailer at
midnight last night it's been a while
since anyone's done that so we'll break
it down this is going to be my quick
week i'll tell you how many texts i got
longer videos soon about some of the
bigger easter eggs here and what's going
on with the celestials the deviants and
the eternals characters the big thing
here is they want to give you the actual
story and i think i talked a little bit
about this in my last trailer video but
they actually show you the celestial
that's probably one of the biggest
things here is revealing what they're
going to look like in the film and they
make a really big deal about explaining
why they didn't help out with avengers
end game probably the biggest question
that people had since the movie was
announced if they're so powerful why
didn't they help and they used kit
harrington's black knight character to
do that they justified by saying they
weren't supposed to interfere in the
affairs of man the funny thing that they
don't address during this though is that
thanos is an eternal from titan and he
does carry the deviant gene so
technically a deviant or someone with a
deviant gene was attacking humanity in
the rest of the universe there'll be so
many comments about that when the movie
comes out and i'm sure they'll have some
moment in the movie they're already on
the reaction because they do talk about
the snaps in the blip i think that's so
funny because yeah he's a deviant in the
trailer they said we're not supposed to
do anything unless they're deviant and
it felt like they put this in the
trailer because a lot of people were
questioning this already there was so
many comments of like what charlie was
just pointing out and then they use that
as their reasoning and they go but wait
a minute is it thanos yeah
he was like the most powerful tv
three quarters deviant they just tap out
and raise more questions then
but i'm sure it'll be further explained
there in the actual movie itself but
they give you the ticking clock here
seven days till the end of the earth in
the emergence what they're talking about
is the emergence of the next celestial
there's a celestial growing inside
planet earth and celestials are massive
massive beings so if you've ever watched
a chicken hatch out of an egg it's gonna
be kind of like that in seven days
kaboom goodbye earth next big disaster
right after avengers end game just one
disaster right after the other tony
stark is rolling in his grave right now
what salma hayek's ajax character is
talking about though is the blip she's
talking about the hulk snap bringing
everyone back releasing enough cosmic
energy to accelerate the growth of this
celestial inside earth they give you the
flashback powerpoint presentation this
is a celestial being born but obviously
this is all out of sync in the timeline
like the meteorite that seems like it's
crashing to earth sounds like it was the
original celestial egg seeding itself in
the planet the people that would have
done that would have been the celestial
post so this giant red celestial that
cersei says is the one that told them
not to interfere in the affairs of man
no don't help out during any of the wars
don't save the earth from thanos that's
irishm the judge he's the leader of the
celestial host the green one later that
you see wielding its cosmic energy
seeming like it's creating something is
jemiah the analyzer i talked about this
during my what if video last night the
what if episode 2 video a lot of people
think that he is actually nowhere so
nowhere oh
that would be so cool
during the movie that would be really
cool uh that's true though they have
like what is that called the ember
genesis yeah the genesis embers
something like that of genesis and it is
a celestial head and it starts growing
all sorts of life yeah
i'll bring it back that would be so
awesome if it tied in oh that would be
so cool yeah want all the multiversal
possibilities based off that too yeah
because i was like i'm sure what it will
at least have some type of he who
remains tie in at the very least what if
his cannon so that would be a really
rewarding payoff ultimately especially
with that ending moment when you do see
that it's coming back to life there
that was
i love what i'm hearing already i mean
and then for that episode to air 24
hours later exactly this trailer comes
out it's not far-fetched theory at all
no it's not maybe that's why it was
timed that way as opposed to their
normal timing yeah yeah the way cersei
is explaining it to dane whitman's
character kit harrington's black knight
character is that they were supposed to
come to earth 7 000 years ago to protect
the humans from the deviants that i
think is a bit of a lie a lie of
omission because really they're there to
guard the growing celestial egg that's
this giant structure that you see cersei
touching as it lights up with energy
connecting this to black panther and
vibranium because they make that
vibranium joke at the end of the trailer
in the comics in the past characters
have speculated the vibranium mound was
actually intended for the creation of a
new celestial body you have to imagine
one of these giant celestials just sort
of reaching over into wakanda saying you
know what i'm just going to take that
joint and just rip it right out of the
ground i mean that is a fascinating
theory about the vibranium though
something i never pondered myself and
then we got black panther 2 that's
supposed to be coming out they do go out
of their way to specifically point out
vibranium in this trailer like it's
played for humor in that scene but you
know marvel you know how they are you
know what they're doing so i wonder if
the events of the eternals everything is
connected yeah i get that but i wonder
how what the consequences or however
this ends how much of that will actually
tie into the next black panther movie
they're going to go take back all the
vibranium to make a new celestion yeah
yeah right when they're sitting around
in the circle here all wearing the same
clothing i believe this is them
reincarnating this is celestial energy
coming into their bodies the red statue
is meant to be a representation of
ereshan the judge eternal's characters
can be killed just like anybody else but
they are super strong like they all have
bodies that live for very long periods
of time unless someone kills them but
the reason why they're eternal really is
because they reincarnate into new bodies
as she narrates you see them attacking
some of the deviants this seems like
it's when they first come to planet
earth like they're all standing in
formation like the power rangers we are
here amongst you to protect you even
though we have a totally secret mission
we're not going to tell you about the
other deviant later in the trailer
talking sounds like it's going to be
crow who in the comics i believe has a
secret relationship with theena i
believe the idea with the deviants in
the movie though is that the celestials
created them to protect the life that
they were seeing around the universe and
then eventually they just went off the
rails and went rogue so then the backup
was for the celestials to create the
eternals to take care of their big
mistake with the deviants hopefully
they'll also reference the cosmic
hierarchy of the mcu or the marvel
cinematic multiverse because we have
loki the multiverse war he who remains
now but the way it sounds like this
plays out in the timeline of the mcu
after avengers end game it sounds like
all this stuff happens this seven day
period before the end of the loki finale
okay let's pause for a second the way
the trailer's setting it up and at least
with like the action scenes and all that
the deviants are the villains of this
movie yes but really it seems like it's
shaping up that the celestials will be
this the main enemies in the movie like
the bigger baddie the way how a lot of
these marvel movies go you got the main
antagonist you're going up against and
coming to find out like no this is
actually the real big threat that we
have to deal with yeah the people who
send the orders down the line and if
that's true if earth is home to like a
big celestial egg that's waiting to
crack and they mostly just need people
to protect it until it does like that
does seem like it would entail some
sinister undertones like i wonder what
the motives of the celestials are in
this movie that's a great question
because i feel like that's part of what
this phase is here to question is like
these all-powerful beings who hold the
universe together they have motivations
too though and are fallible so yeah like
what is their true nature and can they
be benevolent what i'm kind of wondering
is what may might be happening
celestials created deviants that went
haywire so they created the eternals to
uh protect against them maybe the
celestials are not liking the way the
progression of earth is going so they're
kind of doing a rebirth sort of a noah's
ark thing that's what like that flooding
uh scene kind of reminded me of because
there's so much biblical undertones even
though the eternals were created to
pretty much obey celestials now they've
been endeared to humans they're
realizing like i know like it's a big
part of them is like a lot of them don't
like the humans who really care about
them but now perhaps they're like all
right you know instead of wiping out
humanity it's not fair to do that to
them yeah maybe at least probably
through cersei or one of those
characters who is more connected exactly
like she'll be the inspiration linchpin
for all them to make a difference and
not just obey the celestials yeah or or
drive a rift into the group even though
when you start talking about time travel
the multiverse it gets a little crazy i
think they just want to keep this movie
as simple as possible because they're
introducing so many new characters so he
who remains would know about what's
going on here but for the sake of
simplicity i would just treat the loki
finale with the true version of the
multiverse the kang variants sort of
manifesting is happening after the
events of the eternals movie you see all
them use their powers just a little bit
they all have slightly different powers
like fastos for instance is the
inspiration for the greek god hephaestus
he makes things that's why richard
madden's icarus characters like oh this
is a perfect shelter you built here i
bet this is built out of vibranium as he
smashes his table nope that one's ikea
all them wield the same celestial energy
that the celestials themselves wield
which is why all their powers are color
coded the same even though they manifest
in slightly different ways like angelina
jolie's character uses celestial energy
to fashion weapons so really the stakes
of the movie are do they have to find a
way to either stop this celestial egg
from hatching or to find a way to hatch
it and not destroy the earth in the
process and also stop the celestial host
from coming back to planet earth and
wiping it out when the collector was
explaining the history of the universe
the infinity stones and you see issan
the searcher using the power stone to
wipe out a planet i'm also wondering if
they're going to connect that to what's
happening in this movie the celestials
are kind of like cosmic gardeners they
go around seeding life on planets and
when an experiment doesn't work out
they'll just wipe it out and start over
again but also the way they explain it
in this movie the celestial that's
growing inside earth needs cosmic energy
so i'm also wondering if they'll try to
connect it to that guardians of the
galaxy issa on the searcher moment with
him using the power stone on that planet
seeming like he's wiping it out but
maybe really he was just trying to
unleash cosmic energy to grow another
celestial and hatchet in that planet i
did a big video about kid harrington's
black knight character and where he sort
of fits into the mcu what his history is
so i'll link that below in the
description but i think the big thing in
this movie is that he's sort of the
point of view character learning about
the eternals for the first time and he's
sort of an audience surrogate like who
are you what are you doing here why
haven't you helped us in the past why
didn't you stop thanos even though he's
kind of your cousin because this giant
red celestial told us he would squish us
like bugs if we did anything i believe
the idea is that dane whitman's
character won't actually become
full-blown black knight till the sequels
or other marvel movies post credits
cross over into avengers 5 with cersei's
character but i think the idea is that
they'll tease his origin towards the end
of this movie like he'll learn about the
ebony blade the curse of his family but
i'm not expecting him to fully wear the
armor until whatever the future sequels
wind up being but in the way they
reference the avengers in the last
trailer they're referencing the black
panther characters vibranium in this
trailer they're sort of connecting it to
the other marvel movies you sort of find
out where they've been this whole time
and how they were watching all the
events of the mcu movies unfold i know
there's going to be a lot of timeline
questions too you also have to remember
that the events of wand division take
place many weeks after the end of
avengers end game so i'm also assuming
that one division the hex and scarlet
witch becoming full-blown scarlet witch
doesn't happen until after the events of
the eternals movie feels like every year
a channel like new rock stars or
emergency awesome can just do an updated
timeline video of the mcu
yeah it's a reliable piece of content it
is constantly have always have a reason
to post
because the timeline just gets crazy but
i think it's pretty easy to make the
assumption that they do save the planet
because none of the other marvel
characters in those projects were
addressing a giant celestial shooting
straight up out of the planet thank you
so much for watching everyone stay safe
and i'll see you in that next video i
did hear at one point they reused iron
man's like arc reactor sound effect
during the trailer i need to go back to
the trailer to find out again what
specific moment it is we've talked
plenty about the eternals so far i know
emergency awesome's gonna be doing
another like full-on breakdown later on
today but this was about what i would
want to learn and get from the video
like me this was a big help already yeah
i had like a break i thought this was
great because i'm already like pretty
well uh up to date on like who the
characters are and see if i can do this
kingo druid
um fastos icarus athena
makari
sprite cersei
who am i missing i know what all of them
do i just want to do
if i can commit all their new memory oh
there's like another one
oh oh i know who is it gilgamesh
gilgamesh dang it how did i forget the
asian guy
yeah
pride over here the one guy i forgot
i don't know something kind of reads a
little bit malevolent about what uh
icarus is doing here i i don't think
he's like a bad guy but i have a feeling
he's not going to be ultimately on the
there's clearly like a love triangle
thing that's probably going to occur
between kit harrington yeah and richard
madden and i imagine that what it will
come down to is like ideologies being
different about this whole idea yeah
like inheritance is gonna obviously be
on the side of humanity and i felt like
richard madden by the time you get to
the finale you're halfway through is not
gonna be on the same philosophical point
of view that's sort of where i'm
concluding with it yeah and i almost
feel like they're throwing in these very
sinister druid moments in the trailer to
draw us away from that to be like well
he obviously has to be the bad guy you
know and so yeah i could definitely see
them going for a surprise like oh damn
the leader is not really the good guy
all right guys well eternals are you
excited for the movie let us know your
thoughts down below subscribe click the
notification bell hit that like button
last but not least let's do a pic
everett baker your name starts with e
just like the eternals you are perfectly
suited for this i mean the second letter
in your name is v which is like the word
vendetta another comic book movie yeah
and then you got another e here yeah
like elektra like comic book movie and
then you got another letter here r which
is like richard madden one of the
eternals yeah then you got another e
like jamie foxx's electro
you know definitely and then you got a t
here like
uh tom hiddleston as low there you go
it all fits and then there's another t
you got yeah like tom hardy is venom in
spumc mr baker like dylan baker
the spider-man trilogy yeah dr connors
you are are perfectly suited for this
shout out thank you for being part of
our patreon page and thank you for your
support
you rock my socks
[Music]